[Music]
bring it on
and keeping lists equal month I give you
one of the sequels I've gotten the most
requests to review the secret of men to
Timmy to the rescue
God had a lot of people told me to
review this maybe because I pressed the
first one as an animated classic and
even amid to it being one of my favorite
movies
the story thought mrs. Brisby in the
rats of NIMH was dark dramatic yet still
has an element of wonder that makes it
what I consider a masterpiece of
animation so as you can imagine I'm not
looking forward to this one just look at
the cup mrs. Brisby isn't even on it and
who's to start out Timmy Timmy that kid
that just got one line in the first bill
look if he ever done apply them not die
my let's see what the damages let's dive
right into secret admin to till the
movie begins with the not so wise idea
I'm showing a footage from the first
film making us realize how much we're
gonna hate this one they went the
expense they become intelligent none of
them would have survived went after the
incredible bravery of that Great Mouse
Jonathan Brisby we must leave no
evidence that the rats of NIMH ever
existed but Jonathan Brisby Widow and
her family stayed behind
oh nice mrs. Brisby after all the shit
she's been through gets the incredible
honor of widow credit Oh
she also did a few other things but fuck
it they were important the Prophet
Nicodemus predicted that NIMH will again
trust its evil on events and a son of
Jonathan Brisby
chosen to save them no no II didn't you
just made that up
insert immediate downgrade in animation
and we see where our current story
begins we think Timmy and his brother
Martin writing each other's nothing so
some evil scientists are following them
fortunately they give them the slip here
oh don't call me that Martin
you're the hero type Nicodemus were
chosen you for once you're right I'm
older and stronger than you it's funny
Valley wanna Jonathan Brisby son why did
they pick the right wait a minute why is
it suddenly Timmy was picked to be the
chosen watch I can add two sons made a
prophecy just pulled out of your ass
into anything about Timmy being a hero
so what does it more than have a shot
fire oh I know you're trying just
remember some try breathe easy there is
no try so we've seen the rest of the
family all grown up including mrs.
Brisby
who I guess became nearsighted in
between movies mom you don't want to go
Timmy we all know what your father meant
to the rats of thorn Valley helped him
get away from him pop was a real hero
that's right and I know and you want me
to be like him but but nothing boy no
pressure on this kid they just gave him
a direct order to be exactly like your
father the great hero God do you think
Jesus's parents acted that way now Jesus
you know your mother and I are very very
proud of you
but if it's at all possible be mind
Iverson just asking American so it's
sort of hard to understand but I guess
Timmy is being sent to the rats to Train
in their ways and become a stronger
person you know just leaving the rest of
the kids to waste their non profit eyes
lives away of course you're welcome to
thorn Valley this plenty of Education
for oh you're not a messiah are ya yeah
public schools right down the street in
for that matter I thought the rest web
forum Valley that doesn't look like a
thorn bush it looks more like a tree
something that would change all their
business cards so Jeremy finally drops
Timmy off at the valley well good maybe
here they'll finally treat him like a
normal bowel really wanna relax then
take what you please this can be done
it's all made of cheese cheese so you're
gonna treat him like a god - doing the
red carpet you thrown a parade you know
I'm sorry I'm still gonna dwell on it
you do not treat your child this way
especially if you haven't done anything
yet it employs a ton of pressure and
stress that could start a little brat
for life it's basic psychology 101 if
family should be doing it and it's
school should be doing it easier now I
know what you're thinking Paul Morris
acted that way with Harry Potter
treating him like a child prodigy well
folks maybe Hogwarts isn't that greatest
school wake up
what's the traffic ality rate up to
again healthy droughts happen urge us
just for their equivalent of water polo
I will trust them oh by the way over
here we keep turning out anyway
I thought so after meeting mr. ages and
Justin who was voiced by Liam H Macey
for some reason for Bali teaches Timothy
all about their science and technology
you know Timmy when your father saved
the rats of NIMH he didn't know that was
his destiny but I'm not my father let's
let history be the judge of that shall
we
I get the feeling the history is going
to say you are your father whether you
like it or not but Justin I don't feel
that so literally the next 20 minutes or
so is just building up what a fucking
godsend timmy is going to me you've got
to be ready mentally and physically ha
ha to fulfill your destiny everyone
keeps saying that but I don't know what
I'm supposed to do right now nobody does
Timmy you've got to adapt and improvise
it really is incredible nothing about
this kid indicates that he has great
intelligence or great leadership skills
I'm sorry except for the great prophecy
ok Nicodemus was a wise soul and could
predict a lot of things that we're going
to happen but you know what he sure
couldn't predict when a fucking brick
was gonna fall and then crush him into a
Knick up pancake so I think that means
he can make a mistake every once in a
while now much so Timmy shows all some
of his new skills by setting traps for
dangerous wildlife not always make won't
be on a breakfast anymore
well at least I know what happened to
the weather balloon I asked you to get
to me hmm
I'm sorry I was just trying to help make
the valley safe the valley is safe
enough oh yeah except of course for that
fucking snake what does I've been trying
to teach you all these months um that
it's OK for guys to wear the same
underwear three days in a row well that
was just between us maybe even wearing
pants some mr. ages explains why Timmy
snake experiment isn't as good if you
think that you'd be if snakes go flying
through the air humans might find out
about thorn Valley and then we might be
in real danger from who from man one
worm let's hope you never
find out wait a minute he doesn't even
know what NIM is what are they telling
that kid who I gotta say some rest from
the Nazis only see the big picture I
don't never be you never live up to the
deeds that you did why don't I have you
oh great now we can add can't sing to
his resume you know if you were to apply
to any other fancy school he'd be thrown
out in a mill upset so what makes you
think you're Harvard material well I
can't do anything haven't done anything
don't plan on doing anything I'm the
Messiah
I wanna keep seeing either he's gonna
bear this shoe but what the now you're
not so Timmy grows up into a teenager
played by The Karate Kid himself Ralph
Macchio and guess what he can't sing
either and they'll tell our stories
they'll know what we done shion kiba key
on key off so after all his training on
their very first adventure to obtain
food what does the little tinny end up
doing they give him a whistle to blow in
kp5 trouble Oh bullshit all everybody
ever tells him is he's our hero he's the
chosen one
now you're telling him is best it needs
to be a whistleblower what kind of mixed
message if you try to tell this kid no
much but he comes across another Mouse
named Jeff what turns out actually
escaped from Tim you left your post you
put us all in danger tonight you've got
to learn to listen you always think you
know better than everyone else
hey I wonder where he got that idea
maybe what's the fucking parade
proclaiming ain't no better than
everyone else much so jenny explains how
our parents are being held at him and
how the experiments are getting more and
more out of control mostly being run by
a crazy scientist named Valentine dr.
Valentine is crazier than ever
parents and the other sent me to find
you so this must be the rescue the movie
was talking about well great why don't
we get going I'm afraid you ask too much
of us miss me bride why the council
decided that the risk to thorn Valley
was just too great
before Valley isn't going what the fuck
are you talking about
the answer's no isn't it ma'am I
answered your question I answered the
darn I'm cooperating here and there
there's no we're doing all we can
I guess I'm going to have to do it
myself I'm not going to let anything
happen to my mother and father and
that's that can't let you leave oh wait
a minute now they're holding her against
her will
good night children sorry to keep you a
prisoner
what the hell wasn't a random men become
a hostage halt
how do you know about thorn Valley when
I was little I remember a mouse in the
cage next to ours telling my parents how
the rats that escaped from NIMH had
settled in a place called thorn Valley I
remember I'm saying it was South by
South myself Morton said that how do you
know my mom's letter said he disappeared
she had no idea what happened to him
wait wait wait wait
letter what letter we never saw a letter
Martin's missing what did that happen
she says this happen when she was little
Marta's been gone that long how come it
doesn't affect any your fucking brother
is gone and all you do is stuff your
face and sing off-key with you this is
our Savior doesn't even give a shit what
his own flesh and blood disappear how it
can react if a rappers name ever got
abducted Timmy quick Justin's been
captured oh okay then
oh my god wait now
Oh God just has been captured I have to
do something so Timmy after just a mere
couple of years after hearing the news
finally goes to save his brother along
with Jenny who's off to save her parents
but a nasty Hawk burst their bubble and
they plummet to the ground they come
across a caterpillar who says he can
lead them to the great owl which it
turns out is not the great owl but
actually Jeremy posing as the great owl
now if you even care an inkling about
the first film at all you're probably
asking why well it's so Jeremy in the
caterpillar can stand people out of
money by charging them for asking
questions hey here's a question mr. owl
um what the fuck - animals need with
money your you know animals hearty wait
so just to recap everybody Jeremy's a
criminal jumped into mr. HS or
kidnappers and Timmy doesn't even bat an
eye as his brother is being tortured for
several years
sheesh and I thought the first film was
dark this is downright diabolical
so Jeremy finally flies Timmy and Jenny
to NIM and they turn about Justin and
mr. ages had a change of heart and
decide to join them as well and he has
to be honest as we near the third act of
this film I'm not seeing the spectacular
badness it's supposed to have I mean
don't get me wrong it's bad but it's
just on a basic dumb sequel bad I mean
nothing really propelled it into
incredibly awful Jenny look what
happened turn humans into dog okay so
the evil scientist is turning the other
scientists into dogs why would he do
that and he's turning your ass into
bodyguard what exactly is this guy's
evil plan how I have changed a beat but
for the better don't you think
Hiro Morgan what it's me the new and
improved Marty and I made the most of it
Oh Martin is the bad guy Martin I was
far too smart from the venom and he has
the voice of Eric Idle I began to grow a
little bit heinous every day had my own
plans for him
he thought I was tamed and he is the
auditor the side isn't a dog and they
all do as I say no one found in my way
everybody here is happy what I have a
flight
objects I can do as I please I can
change things with these horns or
heralding whatever I control the wind
and whether we can rule the world
together
if you come with me you'll be happy oh
so happy when you come here you'll be
king on every single all that you can
see say yes here know what we too can do
you and me me and you fuck yourself up
don't look so down I'm awesome and can't
be for real
it can't be nobody could possibly be
this stupid
it has to be a dream speak with her yeah
it's like anyway built designed by
Charles Manson somebody else took over
this movie in a sane asylum probably
you'll be happy nice I'm happy if you
just say yeah I'm at a loss for words I
mean this is got to be the freakin
dumbest twins I've ever seen in my life
I mean the mouth is a mad scientist what
sick twisted brain look anomaly
something so stupid
and then the mouse turns into a mad
scientist and we praise all is some
genius this is a white genius I'm gonna
call my creative consultant and see what
he thinks
so the mouse becomes the mad scientist
ain't really an absolutely brilliant Oh
where you bring em on your sense of time
you say no I know now every child in the
world will know they can never escape
I mean incredible it's absolutely
incredible you know what this is like oh
no no no no no no no I came to make the
comparison
I can't it's to feel gonna make us true
it's so true the secret of them this
wonderful creative film has officially
become about a mouse with scientific
abilities trying to take over the world
you know a need of God gee Martin what
are we gonna do tonight the same thing
we do have a life stupid charges I
gather the lab sent in me and the brain
getting me and the brain one is a genius
and also insane the take over the world
and what racists equals and we'll see
that in me and the burning so after
whatever the hell we just witnessed what
will last up to me and tells Jenny that
he's going to take over thorn Valley and
make her his queen why because the movie
was written by monkeys so Timmy manages
to get out of his cage and goes to stop
his brother and save everybody I'm still
William huh so when he gets down to it
the actual secret of NIMH in this movie
was a totally insane mouth who had the
voice of Erica
I assume it looks pretty well keep
secret Lana forget that so how does he
defeat this diabolical genius he throw
the book at it that's for being so evil
wig
they help everybody escape but the place
catches fire and Tingy wants to go into
savemart
where are you going I'm doing what you
said I'm following my heart well I love
you too wait except that very fast
didn't they think let's not I had a lot
of time to get rolled a cliche oh and
practice makes perfect don't confront
benda there's no place like home
bye he plans Martin and manages to get
him out of there before the place burns
up they get back to thorn Valley and
everybody throws a big parade for him oh
by the way Timmy is Jenny are in law if
you think that's equipment in my review
don't it's a quiz no in the movie - and
it also turns out those Martin's back to
normal how because they put a bandage on
his head
and in old kids movies that seems to fix
everything you can be dying of cancer
and a fucking bandage on your head with
pheasant you single handedly saves thorn
Valley Martin is correct Timothy the
prophecy of Nicodemus came true you have
indeed fulfilled your destiny
so let me get this straight Timmy's
great destiny wants to savage Ellis
mastermind who would've been a jealous
mastermind i lucky her that Timmy had a
great destiny in other words if they
didn't fucking bill them off none of
this would have happened
talk about a self-fulfilling prophecy
you dumbasses
[Music]
[Applause]
folks what can I say well how about this
it's awful incredibly incredibly awful I
mean it's our fab and
mass sequel bad and then it just spirals
into a world of absolute insanity the
choices they made to go with this story
are just mind-boggling
I still can't comprehend it the only
thing that's where mostly entertaining
about this film is Eric Idle doing the
voice of Martin but even then that's
just because he's so batshit insane this
or far not to laugh at their school the
fact that Martin's the bad guy there's
still the fact that they build up a kid
who's literally done nothing but the
fact that stupid simple sound prophecy
the fact that this is Brisby and barely
in it or the rest of the family for that
matter
yes thank God some terrible and I'm not
gonna stand for it
something has to be done
do it alright you may fire when ready
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and sequel
month is almost over just one more movie
I don't even care what the hell it is
it's so let's take care that's coming
from somewheres up in the sky
[Music]
fried as a Firefly
and send a wish out if you just say
a bit of paper that one day